à
voici plusieurs semaines déjà que les
rues ont été ornées de drapeaux une fête
foraine s'est installé en viennent dans
le quartier du port des lumières
colorées brille dans la nuit
heller s'emplit d'une musique joyeuse la
foule savoure à l'avancé réjouissante à
venir et sa fierté est presque palpable
le jour de la fête nationale arrive
enfin qui rassemble dans la liesse la
nation toute entière
sommes-nous aux états unis en france en
angleterre au japon en italie
aujourd'hui ces gens ne font pas que
célébrer un événement heureux ils
manifestent la fierté sincères qu'ils
éprouvent à l'égard de leur pays
ces gens sont les citoyens de monaco
même
monaco est une principauté proche du p
pour beaucoup la démocratie est le seul
système politique équitable pour le
peuple
la principauté de monaco un état
indépendant doté d'une constitution est
gouvernée par un prince ou pouvoirs
étendus est l'exception qui confirme la
règle
le régime politique de la principauté
fonctionne parfaitement
il s'inspire à bien des égards de la
démocratie et la population en est
pleinement satisfaite
niché au coeur de la riviera française
sur la côte d'azur
ce charmant pays jouit de la douceur de
son climat son nom n'évoque pas
seulement luxe et élégance
monaco est aussi un centre commercial où
sont implantées de nombreuses industries
et institutions financières depuis
longtemps la principauté symbolise le
raffinement une réputation que lui vaut
une qualité de vie admiré par le reste
du monde
monaco s'étend sur une étroite bande
côtière de quatre km de long son point
le plus élevé culmine à 161 mètres
d'altitude et sa largeur varie de 200 à
300 mètres avec une superficie globale
de 195 hectares seulement la principauté
n'est pas plus grande que central park à
new york près d'un sixième de sa
superficie a été gagnée sur la mer au
cours des 20 dernières années
la principauté ne compte qu'une seule
commune monaco dont les limites coïncide
avec celle de l'état la commune est
divisée en cinq sections monaco-ville la
vieille ville pour tyché juché sur son
rocher avec son palais princier ses
remparts ses jardins la cathédrale et le
musée océanographique
la condamine le quartier du port
monte carlo fondée en 1866 par le prince
charles iii qui lui a donné son nom
ans
oh
c'est ici que se trouve le casino
célèbre dans le monde entier
les hôtels de luxe la plage du larvotto
et le monte-carlo sporting club
oh
e
le quartier de fontvieille véritable
exploit technologique sur ses terres
pleins de 22 hectares conquis sur la mer
ont été construits un centre résidentiel
et touristique
un complexe sportif un port de plaisance
et une zone industrielle non polluantes
et enfin le quartier des monnaies getty
et son jardin exotique
le français la langue officielle des
trente mille habitants de la principauté
plus de 83 % des résidents sont
étrangers les français représentant à
eux seuls près de 41 % de la population
totale les nationaux monégasques eux
sont un peu moins de 6000 la grande
majorité des habitants de monaco parlent
et comprennent l'italien et l'anglais et
le monégasque hull en traditionnel du
pays est enseignée dans les écoles la
monnaie officielle et le franc français
des pièces monégasque ayant la même
valeur que les pièces françaises sont
également en circulation mais ne sont
généralement pas accepter à l'étranger
monaco s'est doté d'un régime fiscal
particulier aucun résident ne paie
d'impôts directs à l'exception des
français venus s'installer dans la
principauté après 1957 les sociétés
elles sont imposables sur le chiffre
d'affaires et sur les bénéfices le
catholicisme est religion d'état mais la
liberté de culte est garantie par la
constitution d aujourd hui tu es avec
l'aide de dieu est la devise des princes
monégasque et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
grâce à une sorte d'intervention divine
que monaco a acquis sa souveraineté sous
le règne des grimaldi
monaco est aujourd'hui un état membre de
l'onu une nation reconnue par la
communauté internationale mais le passé
est là pour le prouver son existence
même a souvent été contestée
rené novella ambassadeur de monaco en
italie et historiens de renom nous
raconte brièvement l'histoire originale
de son pays
la première mention écrite de monaco se
trouve dans la péri et jez des cats et
demi les quelques 500 ans avant
jésus-christ décrivant l'air l'arc
septentrionale de la méditerranée et
kate et demi les sites uniquement
nardone marseille monoï cos police
vigousse ticket c'est à dire monaco
ville de ligurie intema lieux et l'île
d'elbe
il n'est pas question d autres grandes
cités que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
dans cet arc septentrionale l'histoire
de monaco remonte en vérité la
préhistoire déjà à l'époque du
paléolithique nos cavernes sont habités
à l'époque romaine auguste créé le
fameux trophée qui est au dessus de
monaco à la turbie pour marquer la
limite entre la gaule cisalpine et la
gaule transalpine pendant le moyen âge
monaco subi le sort de toutes les villes
et de tous les pays de la côte
constamment assailli par les sarrasins
durant la domination génoise qui débute
11 162 le rocher de monaco est le
théâtre de lutte féroce que se livrent
les deux principales factions rivales de
gênes les gibelins favorable à
l'empereur germanique et les belles
partisans du pape en 12 115 et gibelin
s'empare du rocher et construisent une
forteresse à l'emplacement du palais
actuelle et c'est en 12 197 que le
premier grimaldi fait son apparition ici
à l'époque où les guelfes et le gibolin
s'entre déchirent sur le sol de l'italie
due chaque fois que l'une des factions
connaît la défaite
elle a pour habitude de venir se
réfugier du côté de la provence les est
ainsi qu'en 12 197 les guelfes ayant
perdu la bataille arrive à monaco avec
françois grimaldi à leur tête et le 8
janvier
déguisé en moine ainsi que tous ces
soldats qui ont revêtu également la robe
de bure françois grimaldi pénètre dans
le palais pendant le siècle qui suit on
le chassera les guelfes reviendront
repartiront il faut attendre le
quinzième pour que la situation se
stabilise vraiment
le souvenir de la prise de monaco par
françois de grimaldi et perpétuer dans
les armes de la famille qui représente
deux moines brandissant une épée ce jour
mémorable marque le début du règne des
grimaldi et en 16 112 honoré de est le
premier de la dynastie à prendre le
titre de prince
en 1793 pendant la révolution la
principauté est un excellent la
république française rebaptisé forêt
recul elle n'est plus qu'une ville
ordinaire des alpes-maritimes
le prince et sa famille sont emprisonnés
leurs biens dispersés et le palais
transforme en hospice et célèbre parce
qu'il dirige dans ce palais même son
orchestre il entretient une riche
correspondance conserver ici aux
archives du panais avec les plus grands
musiciens de l'époque on aurait trois
poursuivra cette politique
malheureusement qui cette politique sera
brutalement interrompue par les
événements douloureux de la révolution
française
la belle-fille de narrer 3 charlotte de
choisel stainville sera d'ailleurs
guillotiné elle fera partie de la
dernière charrette avec le célèbre pour
être français andré chénier comme elle
avait très peur au moment de se rendre
sur l'échafaud elle ne voulait pas
montrer frayères et elle a décidé de
briser la vitre de la fenêtre de sa
cellule elle a pris un petit morceau de
verre % taille et légèrement une veine
prélever un peu de sang et avec ce sens
se farder les joue pour ne pas montrer
sa valeur
par le traité de paris signé le 30 mai
1814 et grimaldi recouvre monaco ainsi
que leurs droits d'autres épisodes sont
intéressants comme celui que rapporte
dumas c'est le prince honoré cinq qui
après le traité de paris a retrouvé la
totalité de ses terres et redescend sur
monaco il rencontre à golfe juan
l'empereur napoléon de retour de l'île
d'elbe pour les fameux 100 jours et
napoléon lui demande mais où allez vous
comme ça et on aurait 5 le futur on
aurait 5 lui répond je rentre dans mes
terres et napoléon lui et moi aussi
il n'y restera pas longtemps voilà très
rapidement ce qui nous conduit à selon
un règne du prince rainier iii bientôt
50 ans selon fêté en 99
un véritable jubilé car on sait bien que
jubilait signifie 50 et non pas 25 alors
que certains prédécesseurs le prince ont
fêté leurs 25 ans de règne
quand
oh non
les monégasques vénère leur passer comme
en attestent leurs respects séculaire
des traditions populaires et religieuses
celles ci sont profondément ancrés dans
la mémoire collective et sa compagne de
rites et de cérémonie
parmi toutes ces coutumes religieuses
l'une de celles que les monégasques que
chérissent le plus célèbre la légende de
sainte dévote patronne de monaco
la femme des votes et fêter le 27
janvier les rituel accompli à cette
occasion de même que les fêtes honorant
les saints et les princes d'antan sont
révélateurs du respect des monégasques
pour leur héritage historique
la journée se termine par une procession
de torche une cérémonie religieuse est
une bénédiction
la célébration se poursuit avec la mise
à feu d'une barre corner de branches
d'olivier de laurier et de pain en
souvenir d'une légende qui remonte au 4e
siècle une chrétienne a plaidé vote
coupable de croire en dieu fut
emprisonné et torturé en corse par un
tyran cruel
les habitants de la région déposèrent
ces restes dans une barque espérant
qu'ils atteindraient l'afrique et il
serait enterré selon le rite chrétien
une tempête se leva sur la mer mais une
colombe miraculeusement sorti des lèvres
de la martyre guide à la barque jusqu'à
monaco où fut enterré la sainte une
marque signalait l'emplacement de sa
tombe et les gens venaient la vénérer de
plusieurs kilomètres à la ronde
enfin
sainte dévote repose en paix jusqu'au
jour où un malfrat déroba les reliques
avec l'intention de les vendre de
l'autre côté de la mer
le projet sacrilège du voleur n'est je
crois que grâce à l'intervention d'un
groupe de pêcheurs qui s'empara de la
barque la ramena sur le rivage et l'a
brûlée en sacrifices pendant les sièges
religieux et politiques du 16e siècle
les reliques de sainte dévote sur
transporté jusqu'en haut des remparts de
monaco pour inspirer les défenseurs et
effrayer les assiégeants aujourd'hui
cette cérémonie évoque l'épisode au
cours duquel les monégasques effacèrent
toutes traces du crime innommable qui
avaient été commis la soirée se termine
par un feu d'artifice dans le port au
dessus de la méditerranée
cette commémoration est l'un des
nombreux événements qui rassemble les
résidents de monaco la fête nationale en
est un autre
célébrez auparavant le jour de la sainte
dévote
elle a aujourd'hui lieu une date fixée
par le prince
je
c'est à cette occasion que la
principauté célèbre les traditions
monégasques et comme est mort l'histoire
de sa dynastie et son indépendance
vis-à-vis de la france
où
l'histoire moderne de monaco commence le
jour de l'intronisation de son altesse
sérénissime le prince rainier iii
né le 31 mai 1923 à monaco et descendant
de la maison grimaldi le 9 mai 1949
rennais succède à son grand-père le
prince louis 2
cinq ans plus tôt sa mère son altesse
sérénissime la princesse charlotte
louise juliette a renoncé en sa faveur à
son titre de princesse héritière et à
ses droits à la couronne
le 18 avril 1956 le prince rainier
épouse l'actrice grace kelly
qu'hollywood avait récompensé d'un oscar
pour beaucoup ce mariage avait tout d'un
conte de fées
mais le 14 septembre 1982 la princesse
grace meurt tragiquement des suites d'un
accident de voiture survenu la veille
le couple princier a eu trois enfants la
princesse caroline louise marguerite née
le 23 janvier 1957
le prince albert alexandre louis pierre
héritier du trône marquis de beau né le
14 mars 1958 et la princesse stéphanie
mary elizabeth
né le 1er février 1965
régnier évoque la vie de la famille
princière ouvert aux idées nouvelles
le prince rainier n'a cessé de
travailler à la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de modernisation à grande
échelle grâce à lui monaco est désormais
un état moderne tourné vers l'avenir
mais attachée à ses traditions
lors d'un discours prononcé dans la
salle du trône
il a affirmé née d'une volonté commune
un esprit nouveau souffle sur les
structures anciennes
il consacre les principes modernes sans
rompre aucunement avec la tradition nous
vivons un ajustement plutôt qu'un
renversement une évolution plutôt qu'une
révolution
les institutions politiques de la
principauté de monaco sont uniques en
leur genre
le prince a les pleins pouvoirs mais de
nombreux organes gouvernementaux sont
composées de membres élus le maire de
monte carlo
madame contemporain nous décrit sa
fonction la fonction du maire à monaco
est tout d'abord une très grande joie
parce que la principauté est un tout
petit état membre de l'onu bien
évidemment et c'est un petit état qui
est à la fois un bijou et que tout le
monde connaît et le rôle du maire est
multiple le maire a de multiples
fonctions tout d'abord nous sommes élus
pour quatre ans c'est à dire que le
mandat dure quatre ans et au sein du
conseil communal
nous sommes 15 et les cases des lieux
communaux élise le maire et les adjoints
au maire ça c'est déjà une première
chose et c'est quand même une
particularité par rapport à d'autres
pays d'europe
et pays amis et voisins la deuxième
chose les temps et la commune ont
exactement le même territoire la
constitution de 1962 régit la vie
politique et culturelle de la
principauté ainsi que son système
éducatif
elle stipule ainsi que tous les
monégasques ont droit à une bourse de
l'enseignement supérieur sont considérés
comme monégasque les personnes nées à
monaco ou à l'étranger
de père ou de mère monégasque il est
également possible d'acquérir la
nationalité monégasque par adoption
mariage ou naturalisation
monaco est une principauté
et pourtant si un monégasque éprouve le
besoin de soumettre un problème aux
autorités ils ne rateraient probablement
aucun mal à se faire entendre
je pense que j'irai voir le maire
j'essayerai de lui parler je pourrais
aussi écrire une lettre au prince
rainier je sais qu'ils acceptent de
recevoir les gens qui demandent à le
voir et qu'ils prennent rendez vous ça
ne m'est jamais arrivé personnellement
mais certains de mes amis ont été reçues
par le prince la succession au trône est
assurée par les descendants directs et
légitime du prince régnant par ordre de
primogéniture les descendants mâles et
dans la préséance sur les femmes de même
degré de parenté
le prince albert et donc prince héritier
depuis 1979 l'année de ses 21 ans
le pouvoir exécutif est exercé sous
l'autorité suprême du prince par un
ministre d'état à assister par un
conseil de gouvernement composé de trois
membres le ministre d'état de
nationalité française aient choisi par
le prince sur une liste de trois noms
soumise par le président de la
république française
le conseiller des affaires intérieures
est nommé par le gouvernement français
alors que les deux autres membres du
conseil dont l'un est chargé des
affaires sociales et des travaux publics
et l'autre des finances et de l'économie
sont choisis par le prince son altesse
sérénissime le prince rainier iii décrit
le fonctionnement du pouvoir législatif
le prince albert ii et héritier du trône
évoquent les avantages de la continuité
dans le pouvoir
interrogé sur ses rapports avec les
monégasques sur leurs désirs et leurs
besoins
voici ce que répond le prince albert ii
you every day l'une des plus grandes
idées fausses que l'on est sur la
principauté
et quelle vie du jeu c'est à dire que
l'argent des casinos constitue sa
principale source de revenus
la réalité est tout autre puisque monaco
tire la plupart de ses revenus de ses
activités industrielles commerciales et
tertiaires et que moins de 5% de ses
rentrées proviennent du jeu les revenus
des personnes physiques n'étant pas
taxer l'état dépend fortement des impôts
sur le chiffre d'affaires des sociétés
lesquels représentent à eux seuls près
de 50% de ses recettes
oui
le casino de monte carlo a été fondée en
1820 ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
lobby a été la première salle de jeux à
l'époque c'était très difficile de venir
à monaco il n'y avait pas de train pas
de route
les gens venaient par bateau mais quand
la mer était mauvaise de casino est
évident aujourd'hui nous accueillons
environ un million de visiteurs par an
le casino fait partie du parcours
touristique au même titre que le palais
les gens paient 50 francs de droits
d'entrée et personne ne les incite à
jouer l'endroit est si beau qu'on peut
venir ici uniquement prendre un verre et
se promener les gains ne sont pas taxés
et sur certaines machines à sou qu on
peut jouer avec un franc on peut
s'amuser avec trois fois rien ici mais
ça le casino de monte carlo
si le casino évoque un pays anciens et
traditionnels
fontvieille nous projette de plain pied
dans l'avenir ce quartier né d'un projet
technologique ambitieux doit son
existence à la politique visionnaire du
prince rainier pour le construire
il a fallu gagnés sur la mer
l'équivalent d'un sixième de la
superficie totale de la principauté ce
quartier commercial comprend un port de
plaisance une zone industrielle non
polluante un centre résidentiel moderne
et un stade monaco le seul pays au monde
à pouvoir se vanter d'agrandir ses
frontières sans faire la guerre son
existence témoigne de l'oeuvre
entreprise par un prince au nom du
progrès
les mesures spécifiques les interviews
contre way2many après ce but les voûtes
nouvelle aile de fabien causeur de is
also with more in the studio d'inclure
les amériques electronic devices
plastique
elle vise à trouver de cette politique a
eu des conséquences considérables
puisqu'elle a provoqué un accroissement
phénoménale des recettes de l'état qui
sont passés de 3 milliards 250 millions
de francs 1975 à 32 milliards 400
millions en 1992
modernisation et de sophistication sont
les mots favori du prince rainier dont
la politique de développement lui a valu
l'affectueux surnom de prince bâtisseur
la principauté connaître un fabuleux
développement mais celui-ci s'accompagne
d'une politique systématique de
protection de l'environnement qui force
le respect du monde entier le prince
rainier a par exemple été l'instigateur
de la première conférence scientifique
sur l'élimination des déchets
radioactifs qui s'est tenue en 1959
c'est également lui qui a proposé la
signature entre monaco
la france et l'italie d'un accord de
lutte contre la pollution de l'eau la
convention ramoge une station
d'épuration a été construite à monaco en
toutes les eaux usées sont traitées
recyclé avant d'être réutilisés par les
habitants de la principauté
lusine purifie également de l'eau de mer
qui est ensuite rejetée dans la
méditerranée afin de protéger la faune
et la flore marines le prince rainier a
créé la réserve marine de monaco et à
l'occasion du festival international de
télévision de monte carlo un prix
récompense le meilleur film sur la
protection de l'environnement marin
cet intérêt pour la vie marine ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui
déjà le prince albert 1er consacré le
plus de temps possible à ses recherches
et expéditions océanographiques pour
fondé en 1906
l'institut océanographique le musée
océanographique de monaco fut inaugurée
le 29 mars 1910 après onze ans de
travaux parmi ses anciens directeurs
jacques cousteau qui a occupé ce poste
pendant 31 ans
aujourd'hui le musée accueille près d'un
million de visiteurs par an son
directeur et le professeur françois
doumenge assez le prince albert 1er qui
a créé cette fondation
au début du siècle le siège se trouve à
paris à l'institut océanographique
nous poursuivons le programme de notre
fondateur et avons la même approche que
lui le prince albert veille à ce que
soit respectée notre règle fondamentale
qui est d'accorder la priorité à
l'information du public en vue d'une
meilleure compréhension scientifique des
problèmes marre
on
là
au prince rainier ne s'intéresse pas
seulement à la protection de
l'environnement
il accorde également beaucoup
d'importance à l'instruction et au
développement intellectuel
suivant l'exemple de son père le prince
pierre de monaco qui comptait parmi ses
amis quelques uns des plus grands
écrivains peintres et compositeurs de
son temps
le prince rainier est un mécène le
responsable des affaires culturelles
placée sous l'autorité du conseiller de
l'intérieur est chargé de promouvoir le
développement culturel de la principauté
à cet effet il met les infrastructures
monégasque au service de toutes formes
de manifestations culturelles
prestigieuses et encourage la création
artistique est là qu compte plusieurs
grandes institutions culturelles
parmi elles l'orchestré philharmonique
de monte carlo et la fondation prince
pierre
créée en 1966 par le prince rainier en
l'honneur de son père cette fondation
actuellement présidé par la princesse
caroline encourage les arts
le festival international de télévision
de monte carlo a pour objectif de
stimuler les échanges entre tous les
peuples du monde dans les domaines de
l'information et du divertissement et de
favoriser une meilleure compréhension
entre les nations c'est le prince albert
qui en est le président
le festival international de la magie
présidée par la princesse stéphanie vise
à faire mieux connaître et apprécier la
magie de qualité dans le cadre d'une
compétition
le ballet de monte carlo
à
l'opéra de monte carlo
la saison hippique ne dure que 2 janvier
à pâques
mais dans ce laps de temps très court
j'arrive à présenter en général quatre
opéras je les choisis de manière à ce
que le programme soit varié et s'adresse
à tous les publics
nous présentons des oeuvres dans toutes
les langues et les styles sont très
divers des liens étroits nous unissent à
la famille princière
c'est l île par tradition encourage les
arts dans la principauté
elle a donc toujours été en contact
étroit avec les directeurs des
différents organismes culturels
cet opéra présente constamment des
oeuvres nouvelles et les premières de
nombreux spectacles ont eu lieu ici il y
en a eu près de 80 de la publication de
l'opéra voici un siècle la plupart de
nos créations concernent des oeuvres
italienne ou française
mais cette année pour la première fois
nous allons présenter l'oeuvre de
lieberman un jeune américain
son opéra pour titrer pour sujet le
portrait de dorian gray nous sommes
emballés par ce projet est très
impatient de le voir aboutir car ce sera
quand l'espérons le clou du festival
international des arts
le spectacle sera présenté en clôture
les 8 10 et 12 mai 96
à
vous
donc
non
la principauté accorde également une
place de choix aux sports elle figure
sur le calendrier des manifestations
internationales avec des événements
aussi prestigieux que le grand prix de
monaco et l'open de tennis de monte
carlo
la principauté possède également un
parcours de golf exceptionnel situé sur
les hauteurs de la commune
le port présente de grands atouts qui
lui permettent d'accueillir des
compétitions
si la principauté encourage fortement
les activités sportives
elle accorde aussi beaucoup d'importance
à l'éducation de ces jeunes résidents
que signifie réellement d'être jeunes de
vivre et d'aller à l'école à monaco
c'est un privilège d'être monégasque
mes parents sont très heureux parce
qu'ils ne payent pas d'impôts et qu'ils
ont d'autres avantages fiscaux
left and honey gasc thouars chaque année
le prince organise une grande fête pour
tous les enfants jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans
fait des cadeaux ou plutôt il leur fait
des cadeaux parce que moi j'ai dépassé
l'âge
cette fête a lieu tous les ans à noël et
c'est devenu une coutume le maire y
participent aussi
je ne connais pas encore bien le
fonctionnement politique de la
principauté
je devrai mais bon quand je serai plus
grande je ne connaîtrais mieux nous
votons pour élire le maire le conseil
municipal et le conseil national le
conseil national décision ou approuvent
ce qui a été dit par le prince atsede
mais c'est le principe prend toutes les
décisions importantes
il y a beaucoup de violence aussi c'est
un grand pays
pour beaucoup de choses mais un monaco
on se sent en sécurité
voilà aux états unis dans les banlieues
ou ailleurs je ne connais pas bien ce
pays
mais je ne me sentirais pas être
monégasque c'est quelque chose de
spécial
on sent qu'on est différent et mieux
bien sûr tous les monégasques eux
semblent partager ce même sentiment de
fierté
ils apprécient leur payer les privilèges
qui sont attachées le fait le fait
d'être un petit pays et d'avoir
finalement une famille princière près de
nous que l'on voit que l'on voit dans la
rue avec qui on va en classe ensemble
nous permet effectivement de ressentir
une comme si c'était réellement une
famille beaucoup on est beaucoup plus
proche d'eux que dans une république où
on voit finalement le chef de l'état et
sa famille uniquement à la télévision
donc là vraiment on a l'impression de
faire partie d'une famille effectivement
je crois que c'est la chose dont je suis
le plus fier je crois que c'est d'être
justement membre d'un tout petit peuple
qui a été capable de se maintenir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en respectant les
traditions sous soudain un même drapeau
elle n 1 aux blagues de red and white
avec l'appui de la religion car abraham
la cause avant la religion catholique
nous sommes tous ou plus ou moins deux
chrétiens l'entr'aide entre nous mais je
crois que la chose dont je suis le plus
fier et fait effectivement c'est de
réussir à m'imposer en tant que
monégasque d'une manière totalement
pacifique
le principal objet de la gratitude des
monégasques et le prince rainier iii
car si la principauté existe depuis bien
avant son règne le maître d'oeuvre du
monaco moderne c'est lui qui paie ses
dettes
béchir a livré ce mercredi la
principauté de monaco qui fait son 700e
anniversaire en 1997 semble tout à fait
prête à entrer dans le 21e siècle
car elle est une nation parmi les autres
nations du monde
de tous les utilisateurs situés au
carrefour du monde
la principauté de monaco est un pays où
s'épanouissent non seulement les fleurs
de la paix mais aussi des idées qui
rendent l'homme meilleur c'est un petit
pays bien sûr mais il a pourtant
toujours su allier le respect des
traditions avec une volonté de
modernisation
c'est cela qui fait toute sa
personnalité merveilleusement évoqué par
pagnol
ce dernier disait qu'à monaco
les arts continuer à fleurir à l'ombre
des oliviers et que l'autorité d'un
homme protéger la liberté de tout un
peuple